[Music]
Christina Aguilera speaks out against
the voice again we are done as she
releases an empowering duet with Demi
Lovato
[Music]
earlier this month the former voice
coach made headlines when she told
Billboard magazine the show is quote not
about music and even called it an energy
sucker now it's clear Xtina isn't done
talking in a new interview with w
magazine the singer said the voice quote
wasn't a comfortable place for me to be
where I'm just part of a money-making
machine with a new album and tour lined
up Christina's top priority music
she explained quote my kids should be
seeing mommy live her best life
[Music]
christina is speaking her mind in
interviews and in new music she teamed
up with Demi Lovato for fall in line of
bold anthem about liberation there's
still so much that I have to do and like
as it means so much to me to have the
recognition that I've gotten from
artists that I grew up listening to and
practicing too and like trying to hit
the high notes that Christina hits and
and Kelly Clarkson I mean just like to
get recognition from them is a dream
come true the liberation theme is very
fitting considering it's the title of
Christina's new album out June 15 it's
gonna be so good it's like that's where
my my soul needs to breathe outside of
the show you know like a you know it's
you know I exhaust myself for my team I
love them so much but you know mama
needs to be there for her own dreams and
passions to help
[Music]